good morning babies
we have a house full of guests today
not that they can hear me but just in
case i'm gonna keep it down a little bit
just woke up don't even know what time
it is but it has to be like seven a.m
it's a weekend
so it means that this gets to happen
which is rare this is cute
we don't ever
lay in bed
what do you mean what do you mean i'm
actually holding hands the whole time
remember he said give me your hand papa
i'm holding hands like this or watching
it as well hand away
[Music]
i love it tyka's been so
so affectionate these days i absolutely
love it our friends john and malia who
have baby kame
with them um have been staying with us
the past couple days
joe and hannah have also been staying
with us
so it's been a house full of warmth and
love and it's been really really cool
but the coolest part has been how taika
has been interacting with baby kame
and i can't wait to show you
before i show you because everyone's
still sleeping like i mentioned um
i'm trying to get some things done
because today is sunday and sunday is my
chore reset day
so as we since we have guests i'm trying
to like work it all around so as people
sleep i'm trying to get my chores done
um what are you smelling like i wanna
show them a sneak peek of what it looks
like oh okay
look how cute that is
yeah taika has been literally like the
cutest
big brother takame he's so affectionate
so kind
so soft
it really
puts it in our heads that takes them to
be such a big
a good big brother
and that we really need to have baby
number two asap because my old ass was
getting too old babies i'm sad please
make sense
do you even know what your dad was doing
go what was he doing show me what he was
doing
is that what you saw good
all right so these guys are laying in
bed smelling their nasty morning farts
while watching
three
ninjas this one's not even the original
three this one's weird this is like
three inches four or something
[Music]
all right first thing first i have to
get done is laundry i try to um go in
order of things that need less of my
attention i could keep running in the
background so that i can do the things
that really need my attention and i move
in that order
so
um laundry's gonna be one of those i
could put in a load
and as that's
cleaning itself
i can uh which will probably take like
an hour i can do something in an hour
and know that like two things are
getting done so i'm gonna do that and i
swear to god i think i've smelled i've
created my favorite
smelling
um
laundry and i can't wait to share with
you guys okay i've done years and years
of research here where i've tried
literally everything on the market and i
have found
my holy grail of scent
and this is it
let me show you
so first
i throw
some of these little scent boosters in
here and like they're like these little
beads
and they just literally are there
beats
you can tell i've been using it forever
because it's like almost out but
literally that they're there to add a
lot of scent to boost the smell of your
clothes so i put that in there and then
i put some um
what is this called
fabric conditioner
but i don't call it conditioner
anyway well anyway yeah fabric
conditioner
um
this smell right here sparkling amber
and rose so it doesn't smell the best by
itself but combined with this
this
whoops
all right and
this smell right here
is the [ __ ] and i use this one for dark
some colors obviously because you don't
want it to vape so this is the detergent
i use
and boom boom boom combined holy grail
[Music]
i have yet to smell anyone that smells
like this
i'm kind of
scared that i just shared it
because now i'm gonna smell like it
it's okay
i want you guys to smell good so trust
me
if you want to just play with it buy
like the little travel packs or like the
smallest size ever
play around with the scent see how you
like it but trust me you're gonna love
it you're going to love it all right
ready to rock
i do that now i'm going to undo take off
all the nasty sheets put some new sheets
on because every week i like starting my
week off with some fresh
clean sheets it just feels different
like i think that's one of my favorite
smells like having clean sheets
so good all right chores update
bed done
new clean sheets
mama bear dress
i have my makeup on
speaking of makeup i also like to clean
my brushes
so i clean the brushes i use
on a daily here
having them dry i use this and i
absolutely love love love it it comes
with
the rubber
i don't know
whatever that is
sponge cleaner
and then this is the soap i'm almost
done i need to buy some new one but i
love it look how it leaves everything
looking brand
spanking new
after
like eight months of delays we finally
got it in
brown sugar boba and this is the first
time of me trying it since we did our
actual taste test
so i'm excited and also nervous
well i hope it tasted as good as when we
made it
[Applause]
this is a okay got it i wasn't paying
attention what were you thinking about
nothing i just i'm here in body but
thinking about
guy babes or what 100 percent that's
messed up man
i'm so scared now sometimes you don't
you i never do that no i have no idea
it flies out everywhere nope i have no
idea
you guys don't do that
that happened to me so many times i have
no idea every old house where i was
doing greens and then i went like this
and went all over the carpet
okay just to catch you up just because i
know it was kind of abrupt i was talking
about the makeup thing and then bart's
like i was walking downstairs and then
those are like hey you gotta put the
camera on me because uh i want to show
you this but there's so many other
things happening but hold on okay fine
okay so he did it and then we have john
emily good morning
so wait where's baby
oh okay so yeah that was the baby that
tycho was holding
baby comment and i'm it's the cute okay
wait
oh it's good it's the way it's supposed
to be well what the hell else are you
supposed to say no no cuz up you're not
me i don't [ __ ] around i'm like this
[ __ ] stuff well then it'd be too late
right if you were like [ __ ] sucks
we need to have them try it yeah
have you guys tried it yet
okay let me put more ice cubes because
it's gonna taste better cold
do you trust do you trust what he's
saying do you take his word for it for
what uh i'll make a whole night no that
it tastes good oh yeah
are you sure are you gonna tell us the
truth are you going to be like it could
be better i'll tell you okay good i
believe it i believe her i add a little
bit more water
i add a little bit more water than usual
because i like to chug it faster okay
now it sounds like you're making excuses
no i just don't want it to the it's a
little bit diluted but i like like
trying to change make sure my
expectations yeah yeah lower them
this is horrible marketing by the way if
you own a business please do the
complete opposite of what we're doing
at this moment okay proceed
[Music]
it's good but it is watery so i can't
really taste it why would you make it to
water i was making it for myself i don't
know anybody else gonna drink it
did you put it to get it i'll i'll try
one without water
with the right amount
why would you make other people taste it
if it's not even the way it's meant to
be made
i don't know you told me
did you just see what happened i walked
down
innocent bystander i did nothing i
walked down i was gonna i had my own
thing i wanted to share and this guy's
like here put the camera on me
and now you're blaming me
it looks like boob milk let me do it for
marketing purposes market purposes oh
yeah yeah yeah it's professional all
right so business 101 literally
everything that we're doing please do
the complete opposite of that
thank you
i usually drink mine with milk
yeah she is like a 75 oat milk in the 25
water how do you know when you have the
right measurements what if it's like 74
or like
76. that melts you little dummy
ah [ __ ]
ounces houses five ounces
i never follow that i only that's how i
know i always add extra water because i
go all the way i always do um
well i kind of eyeball it but i go
underneath the barbell every time yeah i
mean that's nice
in essence like that's not a measurement
thank you i was trying to make a joke
and it just didn't work and i'm glad it
was
captured and forever gonna be thrown in
my face this is great this is great but
anyway
we're going on a hike
and i can't wait for you guys to meet
baby kame and then see
uh taika interact with him
my ovaries like want to burst every time
like every [ __ ] time so the house is
officially awake we have hannah
and joseph awake we have baby
comic awake
look at this morning face
i love all the faces
tell me
something i i saw pickles
on the phone
oh oh thank you okay
are you making fun of me
no no okay
what do you think about baby common that
becomes cute yeah do you want a baby
comedy
yeah do you want a little brother or a
little sister
a little brother like who like a little
brother that's similar to john or
similar to theo joe or like or kind of
like a baby coming back
why not be why not baby john or baby joe
you made
cutie babies what are they
actually good what are they
cutie butts but cuny bubba is cute still
cute
no they're not killing birthdays
all right you're being funny i'm outta
here
good morning
um
cuny
he loves him so much
um
and then what do you want to
do who's going to change his diaper
you were mommy's going to change this
yeah he's going to change it you you
want to change it yeah
wait what was that that's a yellow
why are you smelling his butt butt
anyway
that's the real answer question why are
you smelling his booklet okay i'm gonna
take all my clothes no hey
get out of here let's go
he ran into the restroom because i was
putting my makeup on and he was like i
smell peepee and i was like
what a good big brother but stop
smelling people's butts okay that's
weird i don't think he smells i think it
was just you could just smell pee like
coming through the diaper you know yeah
like i don't think he's like all that
you can smell it from far away are you
sure about that yeah thanks
to the restroom and he was like where's
the diaper and i was like i was like
it's in the backpack and then he went to
look for the backpack
good boy duty okay like let mama and
baby let's leave them all get out of
here
good job
i'm a big brother yeah you're a big
brother but let's go let's go big
brother thank you
so now we are off
on a hug we're off to go to a hike we're
off we're off
i'm off
we'll all be off
in the natures on a hike
all off
not on
god
so we have reached our destination
we have john malia baby kame tyka we
have our friend carrie his wife we have
hannah and joe coming out of the car
okay so this is uh red rock you guys see
us come here all the time every time we
bring our friends um
and this is like the reserve the nature
reserve side of it so this is where you
do have to pay an entry to get into this
uh side of red rock there are some free
sites to go to but we just like it here
because it has like 13 different trails
that you can check out we've checked out
you've seen and we've checked out about
like five or six different ones uh this
particular one is called
i saw the name
let's see let's run let's run let's run
let me show you
here you can see that instead of
watching me run
look how beautiful this looks
so this one is called
oak
creek
good idea
to learn
it's called oak creek canyon trailhead
we don't know where it starts um but bar
as you guys can see
parked right at the beginning of the
trail
because he felt like our friend kerry's
car just wasn't gonna make it so we're
gonna park there we don't know when it's
gonna begin we don't know what to expect
we have babies with us
so you can see there oh you're so fast
whoa
nice save duty
um so yeah we have no idea what to
expect we don't even know if we're gonna
make it so come on this adventure with
this cause we don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on let's go
we got a stud muffin on our hands ladies
okay where can they call it a to slide
in his
dms vms
whoa
becca look at his sunglasses oh cute
oh cute
i love how you guys are all matching too
this is a cute ass family look at this
look at this where can they watch your
family channel continue to watch this
cute ass pajama fam wait is that the gem
of him it's gemma family
hey
but dude they like seriously coordinate
all their outfits the cutest [ __ ]
they cook
they dance they stream they do it all so
check out their channel because there's
a bunch of cute [ __ ]
all right yeah
are you guys good yep okay we're all
good good
uh remember when i said that we're gonna
walk because um we don't know how long
it's gonna take and we didn't know if
that car was gonna make it
[Music]
we made it alive unharmed we were going
five miles per hour
it was so much better being in the truck
bed than having to walk this because it
would have probably taken us 30 minutes
like it is okay do you guys see that car
driving over there
that's how far we would have been
walking
and this is barely the beginning this
one's called
oak creek
i only saw a.k.a oak creek canyon let's
see what it says
do you bring your little doggy doggies
whoa it looks really cool look at the
floor already
let's see
no before you go checklist okay water
hot screen okay elevation 3 900 feet
low high 4000 distance one way
not even a mile that's pretty cool
so we are here
we go here i wish it would show me what
the terrain would look like
because there's a bunch of trees and a
bunch of [ __ ] here like is there any
water
what else
do not climb okay didn't say anything
else
turn your phone into hiking gps oh
that's really cool
dirt road oh it does say i still stupid
exiting trails that's pretty cool
what does this one mean we don't have
any of that
wilderness boundary what does that mean
pretty cool
horse trail
are there any here no all right
officially trail time we've passed that
sign i was just showing you which means
it's the beginning
of the end and i'm just kidding it's the
beginning it began
yeah this trail crazy you know it looks
super cool
literally
that side over there
is all the red rock side and then it's
still the same area but look at how like
i'm definitely not lush my ass was about
to say lush this looks not lush but it's
not dry as [ __ ] even though you have
plants
that look like this
at least there's plants like i was
expecting it to be super barren
super bold
out here but it's pretty bushy
and it sounds like i'm talking about
something else
but yeah we got the cuties over there
playing already
papa's such an awesome [ __ ] dad look
at him
i would have loved to have had a papa
like papa
he's so fun
so grateful tyco has him as a daddy but
don't you [ __ ] go and tell him okay
don't go tell him that i'm like
saying good [ __ ] about him okay i have
to keep it a shitty wife and i have to
keep talking [ __ ] about park i have to
like
bring him down to earth you know what i
mean i'm just kidding i tell him to [ __ ]
all the time he knows how much i love
him and appreciate him
and i'm grateful of what an amazing
husband and father that he is
okay i'm done so we have found another
stream hannah are we going to get naked
again yeah okay we're getting that last
year
i need you to get that right out
nobody wants to see this ass
no it is
oh cool
oh wow
we came the most
craziest way and we got a baby here go
across okay i'm gonna go across the gym
i mean you can go down you don't have to
go across like you can go
down there
you wet your feet
here we go
this is crazy babe which way are you
taking us he's right here
monkey you're waiting your feet duty
it's warm today
i see it i see it
wow
oh it's cold
hey there's water
no don't put your feet in there
you already did what do you mean i'm not
so we played in the water for a little
bit not too long because again we got
babies um it's about lunch time now it's
almost 12 o'clock so we're trying to
decide
uh if we want to get some shabu-shabu
japanese food um or some vietnamese food
they have this really cool spot that we
wanted to try but we couldn't try last
time because they had ran out of lobster
fur
yes
lobster but
we showed up we were ready to order and
they're like
yep we have everything except for the
lobster pho we ran out we're like [ __ ]
so we have friends from out of town
malia
john
kerry and his wife they're all from
california they're visiting out here
um and we wanted to show them a good
time so obviously we bring them on this
hike per usual
um and then we always want to end it
with a nice good little eatery for them
to go away with a yummy full tummy of
bomb food
so
yeah
we're going back to the car as you can
see
everyone here doesn't look too tired
they look happy i feel like we spent the
perfect amount of time
for our little families to just kind of
get some vitamin d
get some different type of air some
different type of scenery
and then
head out
so it is lunch time now and we decided
to go for the lobster pho we are here at
district one
in spring valley
vegas is chinatown and we actually came
here before they ran out of lobster so
we didn't get it right so we're actually
gonna try it this time hopefully they
don't run out by the time we order um so
can't wait to try it um i'm excited and
oh they also have like this really bomb
garden garlic noodles that are so
garlicky ugh
i cannot wait let's go inside we ordered
it look at this
[Applause]
i'm a wretched lobster
apparently look at that wow
i haven't had it yet we're waiting for
ours to come three already made the
table
this right here is lobster fried
so rice also have this thing called big
bone soup here look how freaking huge
this is
you like
[Applause]
oh yeah yeah that looks good
that's the bone in the meat that they
make like the rest of their food broth
from
so
i love that because i get all the
flavors of the bub rock into that bone
and you actually get to order it and eat
it and i think it's huge so we're
sharing with the whole table but it is
so delicious
i can't believe about to say this
but we just finished having lunch and
we're not done there
at all not even close we're headed to
we're literally
walking okay so district one
was there
and we're walking to get some matcha
desserts
mainly ice cream tyka loves the ube ice
cream here even though ironically enough
it is matcha but it's more so japanese
flavors
um but yeah we're gonna get his favorite
ice cream what's your favorite ice cream
ube
no no that's not it that's oh is it it
is what do i know
let's go baby
and you can't get another one when you
drop it so you better be careful
dang it in yours my mom
mine's way bigger than yours
oh we got two dudes
a cookie
oh yeah
this one looks smaller but it's bigger
how do you know my power tell them i
tell them i have a cone i got a coma
it's taller than yours oh yeah
i got an invisible cone
right here
it's magic
invisible that's with your head that's
just your hand joe
no
not invisible that's not invisible my
ground
so
it
tyka always
playing hide-and-go-seek
it's actually really fun to watch them
do it because taika since he's gotten
older he gets way more creative look at
it oh my god dude i saw those legs
buckle real quick
um so it's been really cool to see what
his little mind thinks of before back in
the day he would find a pole and then he
would hide so you see like i think he
would think just because he can't see
you you can't see him so it was just
ridiculous yeah that's how he would hide
but now it's way more sophisticated
where is he how'd you find me
but on that note guys thank you guys so
much for watching
we're gonna we're gonna just
go home wrap it up chill out enjoy time
with our friends
and relax so enjoy your day hope you're
having a good time and if not i hope it
gets better thank you so much see you
soon